as construction of the outdoor rink in
minnesota progresses
one thing is clear
the road to the winter classic has never
been quite this bumpy
with the upcoming game at target field
looming on the horizon a surge in covet
19 cases results in a league-wide pause
and the postponement of multiple games
yet just prior to the now extended
holiday break
both the minnesota wild and st louis
blues continue to work hard and put up
points
as both teams made their final stops on
the road to the winter classic
[Music]
for much of mid-december the saint louis
blues have been short-handed
although a look at the central division
standings might not tell you so
get up d here we go
even with all their personnel issues the
blues are playing steady hockey
and before the second of back-to-back
games with the dallas stars
find themselves just two points behind
the first place minnesota wild
you know i think as a coach all you can
do is manage it the best you can with
what you got i think our coaching staff
and doug armstrong done a great job of
getting guys in here to fill in for the
injured guys and the covet guys and
they've done a great job you know from
the goaltender out
probably the goalies better get better
it's just about putting guys you know in
spots to be successful we have guys up
front that take on a lot of minutes and
they like it
sonner
this was your game a couple things i
noticed when you play a good game you're
so you're on the puck all the time and i
think you're just delaying a little bit
with doing things quicker with the puck
because when you're skating and you're
on the puck and you chip the speed
you're tough to handle man because
you've got great speed and you're strong
that's all simplify it a little bit
good job
good job get a trick the biggest thing
is the teams first right now and uh
that's really important we've always
stressed that here i think guys are
doing the little things right playing
for each other and playing for the team
and that's why you're successful that's
really the bottom line
yeah good 30 minutes just like we talked
about i got to get the the forwards to
start they gotta when the puck goes in
that they go they don't start wherever
they want move before and that's what i
got them doing
you want to open up your board there and
show them our magic here
this is what it is look at all the good
ideas we have blank
teams are often a reflection of
leadership and since stepping into the
role of coach just three years ago craig
berube's saint louis blues have learned
to stay the course
and tonight
on their coach's birthday the team hopes
to celebrate with two points in the
standings
they're gonna come at us hard be
prepared for it make hard plays we need
a real big team game we need everybody
involved here everybody willing to pay a
price here all right
[Applause]
let's go come on
[Applause]
nice play
[Applause]
it was a good period but i think we
could go better we could skate better
than we are we can attack better than we
are let's go come on
[Applause]
make sure when he flips it you guys are
out here
because they're all taking off
they get into tara singles he scores
crew delicious into tarasenko
[Applause]
big win
great job boys it's hard to play against
us when we play like that
we're on it we're pounding we're
physical and everything goes deep
playing the goal line we're a good team
[Applause]
playing in the winter classic checks a
box on every nhl player's bucket list
but for nick buch's dad a minnesota
native this year's contest means even
more
[Music]
couldn't be more excited actually
getting here today it's starting to hit
that this is gonna be a real thing so
i've gotten to play an outdoor game at
every level high school college in
philadelphia with pittsburgh people ask
does the style change
not really i think you're just going out
there and playing i think it'll be a
perfect venue for an outdoor hockey game
have you been out here before uh yeah uh
just this past september through the
first pitch
they didn't have me throw up from the
mountain i got to throw up from in front
so i think it was like little league uh
distance
so i had an advantage there
so do you know where we're coming out
yeah you guys will be at a dugout here
okay dressing will be back here
uh you have a little path that walks up
here out onto the rink here
boards and everything will be set up on
the 20th we have the decking that's
going down now yeah and then our ice
pans which go up which is basically a
refrigerated floor keep everything going
through christmas and we'll be ready for
you guys on practice on the 31st
not everyone gets to experience an
outdoor game i mean i've been to the
field many times and be able to play a
hockey game out here will will just be
unbelievable
[Music]
as preparation for the winter classic
continues events on and off the ice have
seemingly put minnesota and st louis on
equal footing
after dropping their fourth straight on
the road in dallas the hometown wild
find themselves just a single point
ahead of the resurgent blues
our guys have done a good job we've
talked about it a lot the adversity and
dealing with different situations as we
all have in this world now so all we
have to do is focus
and when the recent coveted surge
results in an extended pause in play
both teams take the opportunity to
reflect on a season unlike any other
every nhl locker room has talent come on
it's just kind of how you come together
and buy into the systems have a great
skate the players are the guys that are
doing the job
they have a lot of good veteran
leadership on this team i think that's
where it starts let's go boys hey let's
go this is one of the better teams i've
been a part of culture-wise coming to
the rink every day with a smile on your
face
that's what it's all about
as the calendar year draws to a close
and the players return to the ice to
prepare for their date outdoors it's a
reminder that in times of adversity
traditions like this
are more important than ever
[Music]
you